il ya un avantage à débattre avec
valérie pécresse c'est que il ya de
nombreuses convergences entre son
programme et celui de monsieur maxence
et vous d'ailleurs qui avait dit depuis
quelques jours depuis que nous a
présenté enfin son programme que c'était
une contrefaçon qu'il vous avez beaucoup
copiée on sait ça a été dit précédemment
que certains élus de votre parti appelle
encore à cette heure à des convergences
avec monsieur macron et quand je regarde
notre programme que vois-je dans ce pays
il y a cinq personnes cinq milliardaires
qui possèdent autant que 27 millions et
comme monsieur macro on comprend ce soir
que vous n'avez pas l'intention de mieux
partager les richesses moi je crois que
les assistés de ce pays sont les plus
riches qui se sont beaucoup gaver or
comme monsieur macron que vous avez
l'intention vous d'aller frapper celles
et ceux qui sont les plus précaires je
pense par exemple à l'exigence que vous
portez du temps de travail imposées pour
des allocataires du rsa de la même
manière comme monsieur macron vous avez
l'intention de continuer à verser des
aides aux entreprises sans aucune
contrepartie c'est vous qui avez
d'ailleurs fait le crédit d'impôt
recherche dont on voit le résultat ce
crédit à bénéficier essentiellement à la
distribution à la finance on voit pas
trop qu'ils aient besoin de beaucoup de
recherche fondamentale dans ces milieux
il ya madame pécresse dans ce pays trois
cent mille emplois non pourvus pour 6
millions d'inscrits à pôle emploi mais
plutôt que de vous attaquer au chômage
comme monsieur macron vous voulez vous
attaquer aux chômeurs enfin et pour
terminer sur les convergences monsieur
macron à l'intention en effet comme vous
alors que le nucléaire est de plus en
plus coûteux et dangereux de construire
des ep r c'est aussi votre choix alors
que par exemple flamanville ses dix ans
de retard et une facture qui a été
multipliée par six alors ce soir je
pourrais vous demandez pourquoi ne pas
voter pour lui mais il ya un point de
convergence en effet sur lequel je
souhaite débattre avec vous c'est cette
question des retraites madame pécresse
vous dites on n'a pas d'autre choix que
de porter la retraite à 65 ans comme le
dit monsieur macron la vérité c'est que
dans ce pays on produit beaucoup de
richesses la france produit de 1300
milliards d'euros à peu près par an et
la productivité a considérablement
augmenté ces dernières décennies par
exemple un travailleur de 2022 il
produit trois fois plus de richesses à
lui tout seul que ce que produisait un
travailleur d'il ya 50 ans par
conséquent on peut financer plus de
retraite et de traité avec autant de
travailleurs quand monsieur macro comme
vous dites aux français n'y a pas
d'autre solution que de travailler plus
longtemps c'est une autre manière de
dire que vous n'avez pas l'intention de
partager madame pécresse à 62 ans je
vous le savez il y à un quart des plus
pauvres dans ce pays qui sont déjà morts
entre un cadre et un ouvrier
il y a six années d'écart d'espérance de
vie entre les 5 % les plus pauvres et
les 5% les plus riches c'est très années
on peut si l'on partage financer la
retraite à 60 ans pour cela il faut
créer de l'activité et de l'emploi de
l'emploi pérenne pas des statistiques de
baisse du chômage sur fond de
précarisation de l'emploi comme le
propose emmanuel macron par exemple
voyez on a beaucoup parlé des dividendes
versés aux actionnaires 54 milliards
l'an dernier avec 15 54 milliards de
dividendes on pourrait en réalité payé
un million de salariés à 2000 euros par
mois pendant un an ça ferait autant de
cotisations en plus pour financer les
retraites si on faisait l'égalité
salariale entre les femmes et les hommes
qui est aujourd'hui inacceptable et qui
persistent les cotisations
supplémentaires permettraient de
financer la retraite à 60 ans et puis on
pourrait aussi admettre qu en augmentant
les salaires et les cotisations en
proportion la finance je veux juste dire
en fait que c'est ce qu'on a toujours
fait jusqu'à présent madame pécresse
comme monsieur macron en proposant la
retraite à 65 ans veulent nous faire
faire un bond en arrière de 40 années
nous ramener 40 années en arrière le
progrès c'est plus on produit plus on
peut se libérer du temps ça a toujours
été cela les grandes conquêtes sociales
dans notre pays et on peut le faire
parce qu'on produit beaucoup de
richesses il suffit simplement de
partager
alors d'abord j'accepte évidemment
de débattre avec monsieur 4 mince je
n'ai aucun problème avec ça mais je
voudrais avant qu'on parle des retraites
vous dire monsieur quatre ans que j'ai
vu le passage de l'émission de cyril
hanouna dans lequel jean luc mélenchon
s'est adressée avec une très grande
violence à un policier et moi je voulais
vous dire que ce passage là je ne les ai
pas trouvé acceptable c'est parce que
nos policiers
et nous connaissons ne pas traiter comme
jean luc mélenchon
sur ses plateaux policiers du jeune
homme et c'est très important parce que
je pense de même on se trouve ya une
vraie divergence effectivement avec
emmanuel entre emmanuel macron et moi
c'est que moi je suis une femme dort je
veux rétablir l'autorité je serai
indéfectiblement au soutien des forces
de l'ordre comme lui je vous dirai
jamais je ne dirai jamais parce que il y
à des violences policières pas simple
c'est là qu'il ya des piliers des brebis
galeuses dont tous les métiers du monde
il y a dans tous les métiers du monde
des fautes qui sont commises mais on ne
peut pas dire que notre police est une
police violente ça n'est pas vrai c'est
l'un des corps les plus contrôlées de
france et donc je le dis je le dit gêné
madame pena cette importante de vos
convergence est pauvre et social on va
parler je vous ai demandé dans ce cas
bien juste pas de réponse sur le
spectacle j'avais soulevé le sujet de
tête avec ce policier de la bac qui
était venu en face de jean luc mélenchon
mais ces quatre ans ils ont aimé la bac
est ce que jean luc mélenchon a regretté
d'avoir été un petit peu fort sur ce
policier écoutez vous avez été sur ce
plateau comme moi à cette enseignante et
juste avant vous avez fait témoigner
voilà c'est pour ça que dit ça et vous
avez été témoin comme moi de l'ensemble
de la scène juste avant il y avait le
témoignage de la fille de cédric
s'ouvrit dr oui et je pense que comme
tous nous étions saisi d'effroi et oui
madame pécresse nous ne confondons pas
les policiers avec les donneurs d'ordre
et la hiérarchie contrairement à vous
nous pensons que la police républicaine
de ce pays a besoin d'être intégralement
rien cadet louis on a même qu on a même
un extrait dans l'émission moment où
j'aurai mélenchon se retourne vers son
clan et leur dit j'ai pas été un petit
peu trop fort avec le policier je crois
que même lui il est compris par les maux
dénoncés comme moyen de sortir je
voulais vous avez même rediffusé
désignation de monsieur chouïa vous
savez moi madame pécresse je ne dis pas
que tous les policiers soient des
violents mais par contre vous vous avez
tort de refuser de dire qu'il y à des
violences policières c'est là vous
faites une confusion voir ce que madame
quand quelqu'un est plaqué au sol et a
le temps de dire cette fois j'étouffe et
finit par mourir et ça c'est vraiment ça
s'appelle un violent ça s'appelle un
meurtre policière madame pécresse n'ayez
pas de nom parce que quand paris
rue vous éliminer une institution qui
avaient intégralement qu'avez vous à
dire contre les techniques de maintien
de l'ordre je pense ça pourrait faire
autrement vous en serais d'accord qui
font que des gens qui ont manifesté pour
des causes dont on va peut-être j'espère
discuter la question de la justice
fiscale les salaires se sont retrouvés
éborgné avec des mains arrachées est ce
que valent rien qu'à tiers mais en
disant cela madame pécresse je ne
confonds pas ses violons les donneurs
d'ordre qui en sont responsables avec
l'ensemble donc la façon dont vous avez
traversé va que c'est une façon madame
pécresse c'est nous à l'assemblée
nationale qui avons été les premiers à
demander une commission d' enquête sur
les causes des suicides dans la police
et demandé à ce qu'on remette en état
tous les commissariats de ce pays qui
sont délabrés et quand je vois la purge
que vous vous apprêtez à faire sur les
services publics on se demande bien
comment vous allez faire parce que c'est
un milliard de bons à 7
1 milliards d'augmenter sinon on n'aura
pas les des retraites c'est-à-dire les
pépins madame pécresse pas non mais a
très envie quand elle est prête à vous
répondre sur les retraites tout de suite
alesi ou pardon monsieur qu'à un moment
donné je peux peut-être répond j'attends
que cela sur le sujet qu'on avait prévu
d'évoquer mon peut on évoquer d'autres
si vous voulez demandera tout ce que
vous voulez mais des plans et dans tout
ce que je veux surtout parce que c'est
des retraites mais on y va aujourd'hui
les retraites c'est un pacte social
c'est un pacte social comprend avec les
nouvelles générations c'est de leur dire
eh bien on va vous garantir
effectivement que quand vous aurez
travailler toute votre vie vous aurez un
une retraite qui vous permettra de vivre
dignement jusqu'à la fin mai au jour et
que cette retraite s'il ya des hausses
des prix s'il ya de l'inflation et bien
cette retraite el aouel l'augmentera et
elle vous garantira vos vieux jours
c'est ça le pacte social qu'on met avec
les générations à venir moi je vous
rejoins sur une chose monsieur 4,9 moi
dans mon programme il ya
l'ambition d'avoir d'augmenter
l'espérance de vie des français en bonne
santé de trois ans parce que je veux
refonder notre santé et je veux une
politique de santé disant je veux elle
stagne depuis dix ans à 64 ans et nous
avons dix ans de moins d'espérance de
vie en bonne santé que par exemple comme
la suède à la retraite non moi ce que je
propose c'est de refonder pardon
monsieur 4,9 je vous ai pas interrompu
moi je propose de refonder une vraie
politique de santé avec de la vraie
prévention y compris au travail y
compris dès l'école et de pouvoir
augmenter cette espérance de vie en
bonne santé et là dessus je vous rejoins
ça doit être un objectif prioritaire de
notre politique de santé pourquoi mais
par longtemps pardon
le sujet aujourd'hui c'est est ce que
les retraites pendant ces cinq dernières
années ont baissé ou pas en pouvoir
d'achat réel oui ou non bien sûr
pourquoi mais parce qu'on ne consacre
pas l'argent nécessaire à financer les
retraites madame pécresse alors à la
france a déjà inventé quelque chose de
formidable ça s'appelle la sécurité
sociale chacun cotise selon ses moyens
reçoit selon ses besoins est ce qu a
permis que la france est un des taux de
pauvreté des retraités les plus faibles
même si peut-être on sera d'accord reste
beaucoup à faire c'est qu'à mesure que
la part des seniors dans la population a
augmenté on a en proportion toujours
augmenter la part de notre richesse
consacrée aux retraites et vous ce que
vous voulez faire c'est une rupture
historique avec cela voulait dire aux
français c'est vous qui allez vous payer
vos retraites uniquement en travaillant
plus longtemps de la même manière vous
venez de parler à un stand n'augmente à
ce jeu comprend pas marine le pen ne
veut pas débattre avec vous c'est parce
qu'en fait on peut pas en placer une
donc je peux s'il vous plaît on va vous
expliquer quand même allez viens de vous
expliquer quand même
raison de salaires et pécresse a dit
parce que j'aimerais bien expliquer le
sujet le sujet c'est qu'il ya trois ya
trois paramètres le nombre de retraités
le nombre d'actifs et le taux de
cotisation c'est à dire ce qu'on va
cotiser aujourd'hui avec votre système
votre système de retraite à 60 ans c'est
33 milliards d'euros à trouver en plus
d'aujourd'hui moi mon système c'est 20
milliards d'euros qui permettront de
deux qui seront données aux retraités
supplémentaires par rapport à
aujourd'hui donc on à 53 milliards de
différence entre nous et les partage oui
non non non c'est pas du tout une
question de partage c'est très simple
les français vont le comprendre
aujourd'hui à mon personnes qui gagnent
1400 euros net mois je veux lui baissé
ses cotisations retraite de trois ans et
non je veux lui verser ses cotisations
selon lui augmenter son salaire de 3% en
mai donc non je veux lui augmenté mes
sensations je veux qu'elle s'avère non
je veux bcg cotisations retraite c'est
l'état qui les prendra à la charge et je
lui augmente son salaire net donc les
ans vous vous vous voulez non vous
voulez vous voulez
vous allez raser gratis non mais c'est
ce qu'elle dit c'est ce qu'elle dit plus
début pas d'augmentation d'impôts vous
vous voulez vous voulez ou le faire 33
milliards de dépenses supplémentaires ça
veut dire que la personne qui gagne 1400
euros nets il devra payer 600 euros de
plus de cotisations retraite pour
permettre qu'on maintienne le pouvoir
d'achat des retraités alors moi je vous
explique ce que je veux faire moi je
veux que le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités soient indexés sur l'inflation
je ne veux plus comme cette année voire
des retraités qui ont une inflation à 4
% et qui se retrouvent avec un pour cent
de revalorisation je veux l'indexation
automatique comme pour le smic dès qu'il
ya 2 % de hausse des prix je veux que
les retraites complémentaires puisse
être aussi revaloriser à l'inflation là
j l'agirc arrco cette année c'est 1% et
puis grâce à ma réforme alors ma réforme
elle s'appliquera elle s'appliquera
évidemment pas aux français qui sont
usés par leur travail parce qu'il y aura
une négociation avec les partenaires
sociaux y aura un dialogue social pour
parler des carrières longues pour parler
de la pénibilité mais en revanche ce que
je souhaite et c'est très important
c'est que je souhaite que grâce aux
ressources de cette réforme toute
personne qui a cotisé toute sa vie
partent avec une retraite aux égal au
smic net au moins égale au smic net
c'est à dire je fais un nouveau pacte
avec la jeune génération
aujourd'hui je vous dis si vous
travaillez jusqu'à 65 ans vous partirez
avec une retraite digne une vraie
retraite un smic net et ça vous
permettra de faire face aux vrais
besoins de votre vie et du grand âge
parce qu'aujourd'hui ça coûte combien
une place en ehpad en reste à charge
pour une famille ça coûte très cher donc
on a besoin de revaloriser aussi les
retraites et pour les revaloriser et ben
il n'y a pas 36 solutions il faut
travailler plus longtemps et c'est la
seule solution et avec non ma mort c'est
votre argent avec mon audition c'est
votre option pour les prix mais je peux
finir à la jeune je voudrais je signe ça
j'admets vos propositions si quelqu'un
je voudrais finir six mois mais blessé
mais dites pas n'importe quoi ne dit pas
c'est la seule solution de fête du
maquereau une fois de plus est ce que
monsieur macro on dit c'est la seule
solution nom vous dit c'est ma solution
à moi valérie pécresse je veux qu'on
travaille plus longtemps bien écoutez
c'est l'acceptation de l'allemagne c'est
la solution de l'espagne qui sont
aujourd'hui en train de passer un 69
jours au ritz est la solution de la
baisse est la solution mais vous savez
c'est pas populaire de dire aux gens ce
qu'ils ont pas envie d'entendre écoute
mais de temps en temps on est on est
obligé de le faire mais pardon monsieur
kalt et reims s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît soyez vous ayez un peu de respect
j'ai beaucoup de rêves je voudrais avec
cet argent pas d'accord avec vous c'est
autre chose oui je voudrais avec cet
argent que je vais récupérer je voudrais
aussi prendre deux mesures qui sont
importantes pour les veufs et les veuves
mais ce sont davantage des femmes et je
le tiens à le dire qu'ils n'ont pas eu
de carrière complète parce qu'elles se
sont arrêtés pour élever des enfants ou
parce qu'elles se sont arrête parce
qu'elle était conjoint collaborateur
savez ces femmes de commerçants ces
femmes d'agriculteurs ces femmes
d'artisans qui ont travaillé en réalité
toute leur vie mais qui ont attisé il y
aura une pension de reversions
traverser je crois qu'il est immoral ok
sur tender la sueur sont elles là
ces trois là je la vois depuis tout à
l'heure la ce qui se passe là donc
d'adresser sa
faveur non parce que je la vois sur
sont-elles nadine jilin a dit s'attendre
à voir les commentaires sur l'émission
même pas d'accord très dense et
techniques mais on en parlera tout à
l'heure où très bien d'accord on n'a pas
donc je peux vérifier vous rien eu lieu
coup peut pas la part vous êtes sûr
glorifier un truc si hamelin pardon mais
là qu'à la situation de ses voeux n'ont
pas de carrière complète et très
importante donc leur pension de
réversion messagerie 4 54% à 60-60
démago et je voudrais non pardon je
voudrais aussi parler du handicap parce
que c'est important vous allez nous
avons aussi nous avons aussi nous avons
c'est important de savoir ce que je vais
faire avec c'est avec cette journée de
débats enflammés monsieur k ternoise et
qu'est ce qu'un baril vers moi pourquoi
je demande aux français de travailler
plus mari je leur demande de travailler
plus pour quelque chose leur demande est
utilisé des lignes retrier mieux
partager le travail non pas d'en bas et
déjà beaucoup les français madame coface
l'ip rogers voudrait aussi que parce
qu'il ya des français qui ont des
enfants handicapés et qui ont peur et
qui ont peur parce qu'ils se disent
qu'ils vont partir avant leurs enfants
handicapés et bien moi je souhaite que
ces français on les rassure sinon pas de
bien pas d'héritage et bien leurs
enfants grâce à ma réforme il touchera
toute sa vie en plus de son allocation
adulte handicapé il touchera la pension
de reversions de son dernier parent
survivant et je le dis pour tous les
toutes les personnes en situation de
handicap je ferai une grande réforme
sociale une grande réforme sociale qu
emmanuel macron n'a pas fait donc vous
voyez il ya beaucoup de différences
entre emmanuel macron et moi j'augmente
les salaires de 10% et je fais une
grande réforme sociale jeu des conjugale
''serait l'allocation adulte handicapé
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'un
français en situation de handicap
joignant un peu de retard non parce
qu'il faut de l'argent il nous reste
cinq minutes je permettrai donc tous les
français en situation de handicap de
toucher l'allocation adulte handicapé et
même s'ils se mettent en couple on
prendra pas en compte les les revenus de
leur conjoint ou de leur compagnon c'est
très important parce que sinon certains
et bien cette injustice de perdre sur
scène à l'occasion juin et bien voilà
sermon à
[Applaudissements]
votre réponse est en passe d'exploser
encore une fois vous dit travailler plus
c'est la seule solution moi je vous dis
que non c'est votre refus de partager
alain pécresse n'avait pas répondu mais
on a combien de temps délaissé moi
laissez moi la développer mon argument
je vous explique qu'un salarié
aujourd'hui produit trois fois plus qu'à
50 ans la productivité a beaucoup
augmenté les salariés de ce pays qu'ils
m'entendent n'ont pas vu en proportion
ni leur salaire augmenter ni le temps de
travail diminuer avant de diminuer le
temps de travail à mesure que la
productivité augmente et on à diminuer
le temps de travail dans la semaine on a
diminué l'âge de départ à la retraite et
on essaie même d'améliorer le niveau de
vie des gens tout ce que vous proposez
c'est un retour en arrière en faisant
travailler les français plus longtemps
madame pécresse moi ce que je veux c'est
augmenter le salaire et la valette
parents aux cars entiers aux retraités
oms et aux jeunes générations derniers
mois de rien 80 71 % des français
veulent qu'on rétablisse la retraite à
60 ans monsieur maquereau a présenté son
projet c'est même que vous j'en suis
d'accord il vous a en effet piqué votre
programme et lui il veut que ce soit 65
ans comme vous c'est rejetée par une
majorité de français il ya en quelque
sorte si nous parvenons à chasser
l'extrême droite dès le premier tour
dans les urnes avec le bulletin de vote
jean luc mélenchon on aura aussi dans
cette élection présidentielle ça c'est
leur truc entièrement de la france un
sou mais est-ce que c'est 65 ans avec
monsieur macron ou madame pécresse ou
est-ce que c'est 60 ans et quand madame
pécresse dit est-ce que c'est là où est
ce que c'est un vrai pacte social
refonder
répondra magazine banner et parce qu'en
disant madame pécresse si l'isi
dernières années les souvenirs après
fait ça parce que on est quand je ne
sais pas faire je sais parler mais
nadine morano madame pécresse ces dix
dernières années les dividendes versés
aux actionnaires ont progressé de 70%
dans la même période les salaires eux
n'ont augmenté qu'en moyenne que de 10%
et investissements productifs a reculé
ce que je vous dis depuis tout à l'heure
que vous êtes une femme intelligente
vous le savez c'est que ce pays produit
déjà beaucoup de richesses que les
travailleurs de ce pays sont très
productifs sauf que la valeur qu'ils
produisent et très mal partagée et
diminuer le temps de travail ou
augmenter les salaires ces deux manières
de faire les mêmes choses partagées
madame pécresse ment quand elle dit
qu'elle va augmenter les salaires que
fait-elle elles disent augmente votre
net en baissant vos cotisations mais
madame pécresse le salaire brut tout
entier est la propriété des salariés et
vous savez très bien que l etat le
progrès social et social d'ailleurs
c'est de moins en moins compensée c'est
vous qui faites les trous et après qui a
appelé les français à travailler plus
longtemps pour combler les trous madame
pécresse c'est là où vous êtes qu'on
sait c'est que vous savez qu'on produit
suffisamment de richesses est ce que
vous ne voulez pas faire c'est mieux
partagée eh bien les français ont
l'occasion dans quelques jours de faire
un choix qui permet en effet d'avoir la
retraite à 60 ans comme il le souhaite
parce que c'est simplement rendre leurs
dus aux travailleurs qui bossent déjà
dur dans ce pays surtout quand il mourra
les mrc adrien cadenas simplement que
les français qu'ils nous entendent
comprennent que si je leur dis des
choses qui sont pas populaires si je
leur dis des choses qu'ils n'ont pas
envie nos mots parce que les videmment
rire évidemment évidemment c'est
tellement fascinant c'est tellement
facile de te promettre que on
travaillera 32 heures qu'on partira à la
retraite à 60 des jeunes et qu'on pourra
gagner plus d'argent c'est à dire il
s'agit si ça vous qui
passez un programme de monsieur
mélenchon mais franchement ne votez pas
pour ça 250 milliards d'euros à trouver
une maison loin terrine les aubenas
crosse et un des gants n'est rien c'est
en vaut rien la mairie temps il faudrait
encourager quatre-vents de dire sont
défaits bon photo merci à répondre les
autres merci
elle était ouverte